مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها كالمعتاد بالعناوي
مع اتساع الاحتجاجات في ايران ودخولها
شهرها الرابع نظام
يتراجع ويحل شرطه الاخلاق
تبقي على قرار خفض الانتاج بواقع مليونير
بنك المنشاهده الصغيره والمتوسطه في
السعوديه يطلق اعماله باتفاقيات بقيمه 3
مليارات ريال
في الرابعه ايضا
المركز السعودي للارصاد يتوقعوا حاله
مطريه على معظم مناطق المملكه
بدءا من مساء اليوم
والسعوديون يتصدرون مشجعي العالم في اصدار
بطاقه هيا لحضور مباريات ومونديال قطر
اعلن الجيش العراقي بدا التنفيذ اجراءات
ضبط الحدود مع كل من ايران وتركيا وقال
الناطق باسم القوات المسلحه العراقيه
اللواء يحيى رسول انه تم تعزيز قوات حرس
الحدود والمخافر الحدوديه بالاسلحه
والمعدات والافراد لضمان القيام بمهامها
بشكل جيد
هاتفين العميد يحيى رسول الناطق الاعلامي
للقائد العام للقوات المسلحه عميد يحيى
مرحبا بك كيف ستعمل القوات العراقيه على
ضبط الحدود العراقيه الايرانيه او
العراقيه التركيه
مساء الخير عليكم
[موسيقى]
تعمل قوات الحدود على فرض الامم النظام
وحفظ سياده العراق وايضا نحن لا نسمح ولم
نقبل ان تكون الاراضي العراقيه منطلق
للقيام باي عمل ارهابي باتجاه اي دوله
جارها الان نحن نمتلك علاقات طيبه مع كل
دول الجوار
ايران او تركيا او المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
والحفاظ على ارض العراق وعلى سياده العراق
لكن الى اين همم كانت الخطه الامنيه
المعتمده من قبل الحكومه العراقيه يعني
جاءت بالتنسيق بين بغداد واربيل الاول
اكيد يعني اليوم ماكو علاقات طيبه وعلاقه
جيده مع حقيقه
في العديد من الامور ومنها ما يخص الامن
والحفاظ على الاراضي العراقيه وايضا عدم
سماح بتواجد اي عناصر تقوم بعمل الانهار
باتجاه اي دوله
ايضا لدينا تنسيق عامه اقليم كردستان مع
وزاره
الاستخباراتيه ايضا
في موضوع
التبادل المعلومات القاء القبض على
الارهابيين هناك تعاون ما بين جهاز مكافحه
الارهاب في الحكومه الاتحاديه وكذلك
مكافحه الارهاب في اقليم كردن القاء القبض
على العديد من الارهابيين والمطلوبين
للعداله بتنسيق عالي وهذا انا اعتقد في
هذه العلاقه في تطور كبير ما بين الحكومه
الاتحاديه والحكومه
هل اقنعت طهران
اخو زيارات ايضا قاعده عن قوات المسلحه
قبل الايام كان في الاردن
والتقبي العاهل الاردني كان في الكويت
ايضا همم ذهب الى ايران
والدبلوماسيه العراقيه ايضا تعمل مثل
اليوم ممتلئ ونعمل على ان تكون علاقات
مع كل دول علاقات جيده
وفي نفس الوقت
الدبلوماسيه ايضا تلعب همم وعد مهم جدا في
العلاقات
التي تمسك الحدود
هي قوات تابعه للحكومه الاتحاديه العراقيه
وهي همم تعمل المهنيه الحدود
هل ستمنع يعني اي تدخلت على او اي ضربات
كما حصل ربما من تركيا ومن ايران كذلك
فيها في هذه المناطق الحدوديه
لن نقبل ان تكون اراضينا منطلق القيام باي
عمل ارهابي ليس سواء باتجاه ايران او
باتجاه تركيا كل دول
نحن نتعامل معها باحترام
نعمل على احترام سياده ولو في نفس الوقت
على كل هذه الدول تحترم سياده العراق
لدينا قوات مسلحه لدينا قوات حدود ونعمل
على ضبط هذه الحدود بشكل جيد
لك همم لن نسمح ان تكون اراضي القيام باي
عمل هو عمل تسلل او عمل ارهابي او اي عمل
اخر واجبنا ان نمسك الحدود ان نحافظ على
علاقات من المتوازنه والجيده مع كل الدول
شكرا جزيلا لك يا رسول الناطق الاعلامي
باسم القوات المسلحه العراقيه
غفران افادت منظمه العفو الدوليه بان 28
ايرانيه على الاقل يواجهون خطرا خطرا
الاعدام بينهم ثلاثه اطفال اشارات المنظمه
الى انه حتى الان حكم على سته متظاهرين
على الاقل بالاعدام في محاكمه سوريا
وتمت العفو الدوليه نظام الاي باستخدام
عقوبه العدام كاداه للقمر السياسيه لخلق
الرعب
ومحاوله انهاء الانتفاضه الشعبيه
في ايران للشهر الثالث على التوالي وفشل
النظام حتى الان في اخمادها اعلن المدعي
العام الايراني الغاء ما تعرف بشرطه
الاخلاق في محاوله لتهدئه المتظاهرين
وكانت هذه القوه احد اهم اسباب التظاهرات
التي دلعت في السادسه عشر من سبتمبر
الماضي بعد مقتل الفتامه سامي البالغه من
العمر 22 عاما خلال احتجازها من قبل وحده
تابعه لما يسمى بشرطه الاخلاق
كشافات مصادر للعربيه وشهود النهيان عن
عدم تعرض اجهزه الامن الايراني الى النساء
اللواتي لا يرتدين الحجاب بالشكل الذي
يفرضه النظام منذ عقود في مقال ناشطونه
وحقوقيون ان الاحتجاجات المشتعله في
البلاد منذ اكثر من شهرين اجبرات النظام
الايراني على التراجع ومن جانبه اعلن
المدعي عن محمد جعفر منتظر لان البرلمان
والسلطه القضائيه يعملان على مراجعات
قانون الحجاب وان النتائج ستصدر في غضون
اسبوع او اسبوعين
من جهاته اعلن رئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيس
عن وجود ماء اسماها بالحلول المرنه في
دستور البلاد يمكن تطبيقها من خلال النظام
الجمهوري والدين الاسلامي
والدين الاسلامي يمثلان الدستور في ايران
لكن هناك طرق لتطبيق الدستور يمكن ان تكون
مرنه
السيد حسن اهلا وسهلا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه باعلان النظام الايراني
الاخلاقيه وشرطه الاخلاق وكان تحدي
الاسباب الرئيسيه ربما الانطلاع الانتفاضه
هل ينحني امام الشارع ويلبي مطالبه ام انه
رضوخ للامر الواقع
تحياتي استاذ خالد
المشاهدين الكرام اعتقد انه
هذا الخطوه التراجعيه التي قام بها النظام
في موضوع الحجاب هو مجبر عليها ان الامور
على في الشارع تجاوزت قرار النظام ورغبه
النظام
الاحكام او القوانين التي يفرضها على على
المجتمع
النساء الايرانيات
ذهبنا الى تطبيق قانون حريه الاختيار
المحجبه بقيت محجبه اذا كانت عن قناعه
والتي تحجبت عن غير قناعه او التزام
بالقانون او ما كان يفرض عليها نزعت
الحجاب وذهبت الى الخيار الذي تريده لذلك
لا يمكن ان يكون همم يعني همم النظام
استجاب للشارع وانما همم
يحاول ان يعترف الواقع يلتف عليه من خلال
همم الحديث عن همم اعاده النظر في
القوانين واعاده همم
تسويق القوانين بحيث انه تكون تخدم
المستجد في شارع الايراني لكن هل يخاطر
النظام بهذا القرار يعني هل لها او لهذه
الخطوه اي تاثير على بنيت وتركيبه النظام
الايراني حاليا وفي علاقته بالتيار
المتشدد
حتما ااه
مجرد الحديث عن امكانيه همم الغاء شرطه
الاخلاق
واعاده النظر في قانون الحجاب او التلميح
باعاده النظر بقانون الحجاب اثار الرداد
فعل همم واسعه داخل همم
المراكز التشدد داخل التيار المحافظ
وخصوصا والجماعات والمؤسسه الدينيه التي
ترى ان همم
الحجاب يعتبر احد ركائز اللغويه الاسلاميه
للنظام ولا يمكن التساهل فيه ولا يمكن
التراجع عنه لذلك همم يعني النظام سيكون
بين همم بين سندان المؤسسه الدينيه
المتشدده او الاصوات المتشدده داخل
المؤسسه الدينيه وليس كل المؤسس الدينيه
متشدده في هذا الموضوع همم لان الجبل
الفقه والشرعي قد يذهب من حول العناوين
الفرعيه او العناوين الثانويه في التشريع
ويرى امكانيه كما اااه كما يعني احد
التنظيرات الصلاه مع مفروضه على كل
المسلمين ولكن لا لا
يتطبق عليها قانون العقوبات اذا اذا احد
لم يصلي لذلك الحجاب يعني تدعو للتعامل مع
الحجاب من هذا المنطلق في حين انا الجزء
الاخر من المؤسسه المتشدده لا يرى ان يجف
الاستمرار في فضل القانون وتطبيقه لذلك
هذا الجدل داخل المؤسس في التيار المحافظ
المؤسسه الدينيه همم لا شك انه سيؤثر على
همم العلاقه بين ال همم بين المؤسسه
الدوله وهذه وهذه الجماعات وقد تذهب الى
يعني الى صراع خفي قد يترجم من خلال صراع
على الصوت كيف سيلعب السيد القرار على
الشارع
الان في ايران يعني قرار ياتي بعد تقريبا
400 قتيل اكثر من 20,000 معتقل
الشارع تجاوز كل شيء يعني لن ينتظر ماذا
ماذا يعني هل هل هل ستراج
ام انه هل سيتراجع الشارع او الشباب
الثائر الان امام مثل هذا القرار ام
سيعتبرها نقطه ضعف جديده يا ابني عليها
يعني في خطوه الالف ميل كما او في كما
يقول البعض نحو هدف اسقاط النظام
انا اعتقد انه الحجاب او ما ما تحقق في
شارع الايراني بالنسبه للحجاب هو محطه على
طريق طويل على المنظمه محطات طويله على
طريق طويل ال ال ال ال
الشارع الشباب الان ايضا يريد حورياته
الشخصيه يريد الحريات السياسيه يريد وضع
الاقتصادي يريد ان ان يمتلك منزلا ان يعيش
همم
براحه وبحبوحها كلها هذه لم لم يجب عليها
ان الله لذلك قد يستطيع النظام الان يسيطر
على الشارع
ومنع التضاهرات ولكنه ستتحول هذه المطالب
وهذه الحركات الى موجات لاحقات قد تمتاجر
في اي لحظه وتعاود النزول الى الشارع اذا
ما استطاع الان جمع
همم انهاء بشكل اشكال
الشارع الشارع حتى لو لو استراحه الان فهو
متحفز دائما النظام هل ستكون هذه هي
الخطوه اليتيمه اذا جاز لنا وصفها بهذا
الشكل نحو التعامل مع شارع اتاملها ما
بعدها يعني هل نحن امام مثلا توجه
للاستعانه بالتيار الاصلاحي بعد ان القى
به خارجا خلال الفتره همم سابق ماذا قصد
ايضا ابراهيم رئيسي بان هناك حلول سيتم
تطبيقها في الدستور
[موسيقى]
يعني قد يكون النظام اسهل عليه ان يلجا
الى
تعديلات قانونيه وهمم
واسكات الشارع من خلال هذه التعديلات من
ان يلجا همم الى الاستعانه بالتيار
الاصلاحي لانه يرى ان عوده التيار الاصلاح
الى لعب دوري يعني العوده الى الاعتراف
بشريك في القرار وفي السلطه وفي همم
النظام لذلك قد يكون من السهل عليه وهنا
ياتي كلام همم
همم رئيسي بان
الديناميه القوانين ممكن ان تعادل يعاد
تفعيلها حتى يقطع هذا الطريق وان يكون
التيار المحافظ وهذه الحكومه هي المبادره
في
الاستجابه للتحديات الاجتماعيه والمطالب
الشارع والمطالب الشباب
ولابد ان يعني وقد تشهد المرحله المقبله
همم
تغييرات الاساسيه داخل الحكومه همم
رئيسي باتجاه
الوضع السياسات جديه وناجعه لمعالجه
الازمه الاقتصاديه والازمه همم الازمه
الحياتيه للمواطنين الايرانيين يعني عقد
نشهد تغيرا في الفريق الاقتصادي قد يشمل
ايضا النائب الاول للرئيس الجمهوريه وقد
تحد من صلاحيات همم الان مطروح الكلام
يعني هناك جدد داخلي عن حد تحديد صلاحيات
رئيس جمهوريه
للملف الاقتصادي الى جهاد مختصه قادره على
تقديم حلول جديه ل- همم اقناع شارع
الايراني خطوه هل يمكن ان تقطع الطريق
امام همم يعني اي موقف خارجي نتحدث هنا
تحديدا عن تحديدا عن الولايات المتحده
التي اعلنت بانها ستدعم هذه الاحتجاجات في
الشارع الايراني حتى اخر حد يمكن ان تصل
اليه
يعني اذا استطاعت هذه الخطوات همم نزع
فتيل التدخل الخارجي او الدعم الامريكي
فانها لن تستطيع قطع الطريق على مجلس حقوق
الانسان الذي دخل بفاعليه على هذه على هذه
المره وفتح ملف ال- ال- حقوق الانسان بشكل
واسع فيه ايران من باب هذه الاحتجاجات
وعمليات القمع التي اعترف النظام همم
بمقتل 200 شخص في حين تتحدث اوساط غير
رسميه غير من خارج الدوله ومن خارج النظام
عن 350 وقد يصل العدد الى 500 شخص من
القتل وهناك معوقين وهنا مواجهه جراء
عمليات القمع والقصاص وهمم همم
يعني هذا المسجل السلاح الذي يستخدم للصيد
همم فهناك همم معوقين يعني هو جارحه منها
النتائج لذلك الملف الحقوق الانسان سيبقى
سيفا مسلطا على على على رقبه هذه الحكومه
ربما التخلي عن شرطه الاخلاق ويتم التنازل
في موضوع الحجاب في مقال سابق لك
هل هو مقدمه سلسله من التنازلات ام ان
النظام انقذ نفسه اليوم سريع
كما اشارت استاذ خالد
النظام
يحاول مواكبه الشارع يعني على الشارع ده
انتهى الموضوع الحجاب اصبح خلفه لذلك يعني
خطوه ااه شرطه الاخلاق هي تحصيل حاصل ولكن
تعبير تعبير المدعي العام انه الذي انشا
هذا الجهاز هو الذي فككه همم
ومحاوله لرمي الكره في ملعب الرئيس
الاصلاح محمد خاتم الذي همم يعني لان قررت
تفعيل شرطه الاخلاق جاء من المجلس الاعلى
للثوره الثقافيه التي حكما ودستورا هو
رئيس الجمهوريه ولكن مني يعين هذا المجلس
هو المرشد الاعلى ده جماعه المجلس الاعلى
للثوره الثقافيه وهم ينفيدون توجيهات
المرشد للاعلى في كل سياسات الباقيه
والثقافيه او رئيس الجمهوريه حكما ودستورا
هو رئيس هذا العام المجلس وليس مقررا فيه
اشكرك اشكرك جزيل من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي
شكرا جزيلا لك لم يعد لديك
من بيروت الكاتب الصحفي حسن حسن
بسياسه خفض الانتاج وابقائها دون تغيير
ذلك بعد يوم من اتفاق مجموعه الدول السبع
واستراليا على وضع حد اقصى سعر النفط
الروسيه عند 60 دولار للبرميل اذ كانوا ان
تحالفه بلس كان قرر في اجتماعيه الماضي
الانتاج بمليونير
ما يعادل اثنين في المئه من اجمالي الطلب
العالميه اعتبارا من نوفمبر الماضي الى
ذلك قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه
الكسندر نوفا الروسيه لن تتعامل بموجب سقف
اسعار النفط حتى يدك الى خفض الانتاج
من الخضار ينضم الينا الخبير في
استراتيجيات الطاقه نايف في الدندني
استنيت مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه ااا
هذا كان ربما القرار المتوقع عند الكثير
يعني من المراقبين
والمحللين هل جاء وفق معطيات السوق
مساء الخير اخوي خالد دعم كلب متوقع في في
رسائل كانت الحقيقه سبقت هذا الاجتماع
وحده منها انه اجتماع
فيرجي»
انه راح يكون في مفاجاه كبيره من هذا
الاجتماع مثل ما حدث في اجتماع اكتوبر لما
تم تخفيضه في معادله اثنين مليون يوميا
ولكن المصادفه انه اثر في يوم قبل تفعيل
قرار
المفوضيه الاوروبيه او قرار جي 7 الدول
السبع الكبرى بتحديد سقف للاسعار همم
لنقطه الروسي في معدل 60$ انا اظن انه كان
هناك توقعات وربما طلب يمكن غير معلن من
من الدول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
لزياده الانتاج لتعويض النقص من النقص
الروسي الذي كان يتدفق على اوبا اظن انه
لم يحدث همم
ويمكن هذه صيغه البيان اليوم لما شفنا في
البيان الختامي للاجتماع رغم قصره انه
تاكيد على انه قرار تخفيض اثنين مليون
برميل يوميا كان همم خاضع همم اعتبارات
الاسواق وليس شيء اخر توقعات الان بعد هذا
القرار خلال الاسابيع القادمه يعني بعد
فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي لسقف ساري على النفط
الروسي المنقل البحرا توقعات يعني بحدوث
ربما انكماش في الاقتصاد العالمي بشكل عام
الى اين يمكن ان تتجه الى الاسعار انخفاض
انا وسعودا
طبعا احنا لو يعني لو استثنين لو كنا في
مرحله ما فيها تهديدات الركود وفيها تباطل
الاقتصاد راح نشوف سبايك او ارتفاع حاد
نتيجه حرمان الاسواق من مليون ونصف برميل
يوميا تتجه الى
الاوروبيين ولكن الان مع تباطؤ الاقتصاد
اعطى اعطى يعني ريلاكس او تخفيف للي مثل
هذه القفزات في الاسعار متوقع ان يشهد
ارتفاع في الاسعار ولكن لما احنا متوقعين
انه نشهد ارتفاع نتيجه الظروف اللي يشهدها
العالم اجمع رغم تخفيض القيود ال- ال- على
الاختبارات في الصين ولكن انا اظن اكثر ما
في الموضوع خالد اخطر ما في الموضوع اللي
اخذته القرار المفوضيه العربيه او
المجموعه الدول السابع هو انه هذا النجاح
هذا القرار قد يفتح الشهيه
لتطبيق ضد دول منتجه اخرى او حتى مجموعه
المتجهين نعم لانه
اذا نجح هذا القرار بتحديد سعر معناته انه
ستنتقل ستنتقل الدول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده الى مرحله متقدمه وقد تفرض اسعار
همم بما انها تملك 60% من خدمات الشحن
والتامين على ناقلات النفط فهو الموضوع
الحقيقه اخطر من موضوع ارتفاع الاسعار
القرار التوخذ تم فرض سقف ساري للانتاج
همم نفط المنقول بحرا من قبل روسيا فهل
هناك شكوكوك بعدم تطبيق هذا القرار بعد
اتخاذ
هي تعتمد على الديناميكيه اللي تنتجها
روسيا والماركه بمعنى انه روسيا قد تتجاوز
هذا القرار وقد لا ينجح اذا كانت هنا
العملاءها ويعني صار ثم ما يسمى بالماركت
شفرولينج اللي هو انه مثلا الاوروبيين سي
سي يجدون نفط غير النقط الروسي الروس راح
يغطون همم
المنتجين اللي اتجهوا للسوق الاوروبي مثل
العراق العراق
20% من انت زاد 20% من تاجه هيك وصار يتجه
الى اوروبا فاذا في اثار التحويل او او
تبادل المواقع هذا لن ينجح القرار
والعائدات النفطيه على الروس ستبقى كما هي
تتحكم في اسعارها او مثل ما بناء على
السوق واسعار السوق لكن اذا نجح وتم تقي
مثل لما مثلا اخدوا موافقات من الهند واخر
واصبح الموردين او مستوردين او مستهلكين
كبار
معاهم وهم يحاولون الان اعتقد انه ستكون
يعني همم سابقا في عالم السياسه والاقتصاد
ويجب ان نعم
روسيا قامت برفع مستوى انتاجها همم نفضي
لاعلى مستوى منذ ثمانيه اشهر وبلغ انتاجها
نحو 11 مليون برميل يوميا وهو عكس ما تم
الاتفاق عليه في اوبك بلس يعني هل في ذلك
هل يمكن ان تنجح وفق هذه الديناميكيه
روسيا في تجاوز هذا القرار اذا ما صح هذا
الامر
الى الان نحنا ما احنا شايفين عندها
المرونه الكافيه وعندهن قدرتها على انه
يعني توفر اسواق لها خارج خارج منظومه
الاتحاد الاوروبي طبعا راح يكون في تحديات
في موضوع التامين والشحن ولكن هذا هذا
يعني ايران كانت همم يعني عليها حظر
وعليها عقوبات واستطاعتها
الى الصين قد تفعل روسيا اذا تجاوزت بعض
العقبات في موضوع الشحن والتربيه
في استراتيجيات الطاقه
في السعوديه
الصغيره والمتوسطه اليوم عن بدء نشاطه
وذلك الساعه يعني نهضه القطاع الحيوي بما
يحقق النمو الاقتصادي ويصب في تحقيق
مستودعات رؤيه السعوديه 20 30 قد وقع على
البنك 15/10 اتفاقيه التعاون بقيمه ثلاثه
مليارات ريال مع مؤسسات الماليه لخلق
الشركات وتعزيز مساهمه هذه المؤسسات في
تمويل المشاهات الصغيره والمتوسطه فضلا عن
كشفه عن سته المنتجات تمويليه اخرى
العقيقه كشف مازن الغنيم رئيس التنفيذي
لبنك المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه ان حجم
القطاع المنشات الصغيره والمتوسطه في
السعوديه بلغ نحو 900,000 مشى مشيرا الى
ان التحول الرقمي في البلاد سايتيح فرصه
كبيره لزياده التمويل في القطعه
قطاع المنشات صغيره متوسطه يعني يبلغ حجمه
حوالي 900.000 مشاهده صغيره متوسطه
التحدي الكبير اليوم في قطاع او في شريحه
اا المنشات المتناهيه الصغار
لحجمها لا يزيد عن خمس موظفين او دخلها
السنوي لا يزيد عن ثلاثه مليون
نعتقد اليوم مع التحول الرقمي وهمم
استخدام المدفوعات الالكترونيه اعتقد في
فرصه كبيره جدا همم
المساهمه في زياده همم تمويل لهذا القطاع
واعتقد بالشراكه او التفاهم ورش العمل
لاجلناها مع القطاع المالي والقطاع المصري
في تحديدا يعني بينت هذا همم هذه الفرصه
خلاف هذا في همم يعني فرص كبير للتوظيف
فرص كبيره للنمو
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
كاميرا العربيه ترفض عمليات المراقبه
السفن والتجاره العالميه في ميناء جده
الاسلامي
ودخولها شهر الرابع النظام والتراجع ويحل
شرطه الاخلاق
وقفي اجتماعي اليوم مجموعه اوبك بلس تبكي
على قرار خفض الانتاج بواقع مليوني برميل
يوميا
بنك المشاهده الصغيره والمتوسطه في
السعوديه يطلق اعماله باتفاقيات بقيمه
ثلاثه مليارات ريال
المركز السعودي للارصاد يتوقعوا حاله
مطريه على معظم مناطق المملكه بدا من
مسائل اليوم
والسعوديون يتصدرون مشجعين العالم في
اصدار بطاقه هيئه لحضور مباريات مونديال
قطر
اهلا بكم من جديد اكثر من 65% من التجاره
البحريه الوارد عبر الموانئ السعوديه تمر
عبر ميناء جده الاسلامي غربيه السعوديه
وهو ما يتطلب تكثيف العمل على مدار 24
ساعه في مراقبه حركه السفن من خلال عمليه
دخولها وخروجها ويعملوا برج المراقبه
البحري في ميناء جده على مدار الساعه من
خلال كوادر سعوديه مؤهله وبجازيه عاليه
تؤكد كفاءه القطاع البحري والموانئ
السعوديه
من مين يا جده ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلامي سلطان مرحبا بك معي وين
السلطان خلينا نشوف طيب سلطان
وينك يا سلطان
طيب كلمنا الان عن العمل على مدار 24 ساعه
في مراقبه حركه السفن يعني انت كيف رصد
طريقه العمل مع هذا الكم ربما من التجاره
البحريه الوارده عبر الميناء
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه منذ ساعات الصباح نتواجد داخل
ميناء جده الاسلامي هذا الميناء المهم
الذي يربط بين قاره اوروبا واسيا وافريقيا
نشاهد الحركه داخل برج المراقبه من خلال
عدد كبير من الموظفين السعوديين المؤهلين
الذي يعملون تحت مسميات وظيفيه وهي مراقب
حركه ميله حين تحدث على يعملون على مدار
24 ساعه معدل السفن التجاريه التي تاتي
وتخرج من ميناء جده الاسلامي نتحدث لاكثر
من 40 السفينه ضخمه تتراوح اطوالها بين
400 تصل الى 400 متر وبيوزان تصل الى سبعه
الاف طن اريد ان اخذكم في صوره همم حول من
جده الاسلاميه هذا الميناء الذي يبلغ همم
او يصل مساحته تمتد الى 12 كيلو متر مربع
في الساعه نتحدث على اكثر من 62 رصيف
يستقبل كبرى السفن التجاريه والشحن بمختلف
المجالاتها اليوم نتحدث على انه يستقبل
المناس قرابه خمسه الاف السفينه تجاريه
همم 62 رصيف متعدد الاغراض نتحدث على
حاويات وبضائع عامه ومواشي وركاب وكذلك
خير من الحبوب السائبه وايضا السيارات اذا
تحدثنا على ما يفهم يتعلق بموضوع المواشي
نتحدث على يعني اكثر من سبعه عمليه الراس
سنويه اليوم هنالك مشاريع تطويريه كبيره
جدا يشهدها ميناء جده الاسلامي بمقدمتها
انطلاق المرحله الاولى من تطوير مشروع
محطه الحاويات الجنوبيه بالمينا تحديدا
والتي سوف تنفذ على اربعه مراحل استثماريه
من قبل شركات عالميه تعمل في تشغيل
الميناء بقيمه تصل الى ثلاثه مليارات ريال
جميل في هذه المشاريع انها يعني تعمل على
مبادره على مبادرات عديده منها همم للحجم
التاثير على البيئه بمقدمه استخدام الطاقه
الكهربائيه لتشغله معدات الثقيله ايضا
تنفيذ مبادرات اعاده تدوير واكتشاف مصادر
الطاقه المتجدده مثل الواح الشمسيه وطاقه
الرياح وغيرها من ال- ال- المبادرات التي
تعمل على معالجه التسربات وغيرها اليوم
ايضا هناك مشروع مهم يجب التنويه عليه
بمقدمتها نتحدث على النقل النوعيه التي
عملت عليها شركه ميرسك العالميه برفقه
هيئه الموانئ من خلال العمل على انشاء
منطقه لوجستيه متكامله تبلغ مساحتها قرابه
و 5000 متر مربع منها نتحدث على استقبال
يتجاوز ال 500 او استثمار يصل الى 500
مليون ريال ابرز مخرجات هذه المنطقه سوف
تكون يعني سوف تضع المملكه في مركز عالمي
في موضوع اللوجستيات والسلام النشاط
الاقتصادي والتلمي والرفع الطاقه
الاستيعابين للصدرات التجاريه بنسبه 50%
يعني كانت توفير اكثر من 2500 اليوم ميناء
جده الاسلامي يعتبر من اهم الموانئ
السعوديه اكثر من 57% من واردات المملكه
تصل عبر هذا الميناء المهم خالص شكرا
جزيلا لك من منهاج الاسلام
مراسل العربيه السلطان السلمي
توقع المركز السعودي للارصاد في تقرير عن
حاله الطقس اليوم وطول امطار رعديه مصحوبه
برياح الناشطه من البرد على اجزاء من
منطقه القصيم وحائل والاجزاء الشماليه من
منطقه المدينه المنوره وتكون من متوسطه
الى غزيره وقد تؤدي الى جريان السيول على
اجزاء من منطقه الحدود الشماليه والمنطقه
الشرقيه
بعد قليل
السعوديه ولا يتصدرون مشجعي العالم في
اصدار بطاقه هيا لحضور مباريات مونديال
قطر
تتواصلوا فعاليات مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز
للصقور بنسخته الثانيه الذي يسهم في تعزيز
روايه الصقار لدى المشاركين وتشجيع
الصقرين من جميع مناطق السعوديه على
المشاركه يسعد نادي الصقور السعوديه من
خلال تنظيم مهرجان الملك عبد العزيز
للصقور الى اقامه فعاليات تخدم الصقارين
على ممارسه هواياتهم والحفاظ على الموروث
الثقافي والحضاري
رياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه يا اسامه
القاسم اسامه حياك الله جديد مهرجان
الصقور هذا العام ما هو
اهلا وسهلا خالد تحيه طيبه لك ولجميع
الساده المشاهدين في قناه العربيه
بالتاكيد اليوم نتحدث عن مهرجان الصقور
وهو اكبر مهرجان صقور في العالم سواء على
مستوى الجوائز التي تفوق هذا العام اكثر
من 30 مليون ريال وايضا على مستوى الصقور
المشاركه التي شاهدت في دورتها الاخيره
اكثر من 2350 صقر مشارك الصقور اليوم تعبر
عن الثقافه السعوديه عن العزه عن الشموخ
عن السرعه عن اشياء كثيره جدا وما مفاهيم
ارتبطت بالسعوديين واهتمامهم الكبير جدا
بالصقور السعوديه من اكثر الشعوب في
العالم اهتماما بتربيه الصقور وايضا
اقتناءها ومشاركتهم في السباقات هذا
المهرجان يعتبر الخامس ودورته الخامسه في
عدد كبير جدا ايضا من المعايير التي
استحدثت منها مثلا سباق كاس المؤسس وايضا
من ضمار كاس او عفوا سيف الملك هذه
الاشياء اتت من اجل تحميص وزياده الحماس
لدى همم المهتمين بالصقور ومشاركتهم في
هذا المهرجان للتعرف اكثر عن ماهيه
المعايير التي تقام في تحديد سرعات الصقور
وايضا ما هي الاشياء التي يقام عليها
تحديد المراكز الاولى يسعدني كل عام
الاستاذ عبد المحسن المشعلي وهو محلل
سباقات صقور اهلا وسهلا بك ابتداءا مع
استاذ عبد المحسن حدثني ابتداءا عن كيف
تقيسون اليوم بسرعه الصقر في هذه السباقات
اول شيء الله يمسيك بالخير يمسي عليك
بالخير ويمسي على المستمعين خلف الشاشه
ونقول الله يحييكم في مهرجان الملك
عبدالعزيز طبعا المهرجان بدا من تاريخ 28
همم في شهر
ينتهي في شهر 16 ديسمبر 18 يوم همم طبعا
السباق هو مسافه 400 متر همم الطير اللي
يقطع المسافه في 400 متر هو الطير اللي
افضل توقيته والطير الفايز
طيب حدثني اليوم عن ابرز الاشياء التي
استحدثت في هذه الدوره الدوره الخامسه ما
هي ابرز الاشياء التي قدمت ايضا
للمتسابقين ما هي الجوائز ايضا التي تقام
في هذه الدوره طبعا مهرجان الملك عبد
العزيز في نسخته الخامسه يعتبر النسخه
المميزه احنا تعودنا من نادي صقور السعودي
ان كل سنه يبهرنا باشياء جديده الشكر
للقياده الرشيده على دعمهم الا محدود لهذه
الهوايه النسخه الخامسه عندنا استحداث شوط
الملاك همم واستحداث شوط صقار المستقبل
واستحداث شوط سيف الملك طبعا سيف الملك
والشوط الاغلى على كل همم مواطن سعودي
ومشارك في هذا المهرجان همم طبعا همم
جوائز تقدر بثلاثين مليون هذه السنه جوائز
ضخمه همم الجوائز همم في سباق المرواح
وتضمنها سباق يعني عندنا مزايا وعندنا
سباق من الواحد همم ما شاء الله تبارك
الله على اعداد الاقبال لهذه السنه همم
اسال الله التوفيق للجميع شكرا لك استاذ
عبد المحسن اذا خالد بالتاكيد الطيور
اليوم الصقور تنتقل من منطقه تسمى السلاح
وتنتهي الى منطقه تسمى الملوح شكرا رجاء
بعدد كبير جدا من المشاركين يبدا المهرجان
في الساعه 8:00 صباحا ينتهي عند الساعه
8:00 مساءا اليك
تصدر المشجعون السعودي والقائمته اكثر
الدول طلبا لبطاقه هيا المخصصه لزوار
بطوله كاس العالم 2022
متفوقه على جميع المشجعين الدوري من حيث
عدد الطلبات المقدمه واحتل المشجع الهند
المرتبه الثانيه
والمملكه المتحده رابعا وبلغ اجمالي وجميع
الطلبات المقدمه لطالب لبطاقه هيا نحن
مليونين طالب في مبلغ عدد زوار مناطق
مهرجان الفيفا للمشجعين مليون سنه
الى محمد القناص الان واخر اخبار الرياضه
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا خالد اخبار الرياضه حياكم الله
خلال مباراته الالف في مسيرته الكرويه قاد
ليونيل ميسي منتخب الارجنتين لبلوغ ربع
نهائي البطوله على حساب استراليا ضاربا
موعدا مع هولندا في الدور ربع النهائي
ميسي افتتح النتيجه لمنتخب التانجو في
الدقيقه الخامسه والثلاثين مسجلا هدفه
الاول مع بلاده في دوري خروج خلال
مشاركاته الخمس في البطوله قبل ان ياتي
الدور في الدقيقه السابعه والخمسين على
زميله ونجمه مانشستر سيتي
من الحارس الاسترالي ماتوريان مسجلا ثاني
اهداف بلاده لكنها منتخب استراليا تمكن في
الدقيقه السابعه والسبعين من تقليص الفارق
عبر فرنانديز بالخطا في المرمى
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اه تجاوز المنتخب هولندا دوري 16 بنجاح
الى ربع النهائي بعد فوز على نظيره
الامريكي بثلاثه اهداف لهدف صنع دينزل
دمبرز اول هدفين وسجل الهدف الثالث الحاسم
يقوده منتخب بلاده للفوز امام الكثير من
الجماهير واكثر من اربعه الاف او 44.000
متفرج على الطواحين افتتحوا التسجيل في
اول عشر دقائق باقدام من في دبي وقبل
نهايه الشوط الاول اضافه ثاني بليند الهدف
الثاني نجح المنتخب الامريكي في الشوط
الثاني من تخليص يعني النتيجه في الدقيقه
السادسه والسابعين لكن بعد خمس دقائق حسب
ما تنزل دومبريس على الامور وعزز نتيجه
بهدف ثالث في الدقيقه الحاديه والثمانين
ستلعب امام المنتخب الارجنتين في ربع
النهائي
[تصفيق]
منتخب وامريكا قويا ومنظم لكن استحقنا
الفوز لقد كنا متميزين ومتمكنين فوق
الميدان سجلنا اهداف جميله وهذا يعكس
اسلوبنا المميز في المباريات تفوقنا امام
امريكا لاننا فرضنا اسلوب قويا ومميزا
امامهم وهو اسلوب يصعب المهمه على
المنافسين سنطبقه امام اي منتخب سنواجهه
في المرحله المقبله
المنتخب
المقبله هذه لحظه صعبه بالنسبه لنا
اللاعبون عليهم لقد كونوا مجموعه رائعه
خلال المعسكر والبطوله علينا اكتساب
المزيد من الخبره هذه المباريات تلعب على
تفاصيل صغيره لكني فخور بفريقه
تسع فرنسا بطله العالم استعاده فريقها
ومواصله حمله الدفاع على لقبيها عندما
تلاقي بولندا الطامحه في تركي بصمه في هذا
المونديال ويتعين على منتخب فرنسا طيو
صفحه الجوله الثالثه من دوري المجموعات
حين خسرت امام تونس والتركيز على مواجهه
نسور اخرى بقياده النجمه وهدافها
لاستثنائي روبرت ليفاندوفسكي بالمقابل
تعمل بولندا في استعاده توازنها بعد
العروض المخيبه في دوري المجموعات وخصوصا
الخساره امام الارجنتين في الجوله الاخيره
التي كادت ان تطيح بها خارج المونديال
فرنسا حامله اللقب بدات مونديال قطر وهي
تخشى تكرار سيناريو 2002 والخروج من دوري
المجموعات
[موسيقى]
الديوك وقبل صافره البدايه ضربه موجعه
بغياب صاحب الكره الذهبيه كريم بنزيما
للاصابه المباراه الافتتاح امام استراليا
قالب فيها الناتج الفرنسيون للفوز برباعيه
مره اخرى احد ركائز المنتخب يغادر المعسكر
الاصابه وهو لوكاسيرنانديز اللقاء الثاني
امام الدنمارك شهيد فوز الازرق بثنائيتك
ليان مبابي مواجهه تونس في الجوله الاخيره
اراها في هذا الشان اهم الركائز يتلقى
المنتخب الفرنسي الخساره بهدف وهبي
لم يكن سهله في مجموعه تضم الارجنتين
والسعودي والمكسيك اربعه نقاط فقط جعل
الزملاء ليفاندوفسكي يجتازون المجموعه
كواصيف للمنتخب
لقاء واحد جمع البولنديين والفرنسيين في
مسابقه الدوليه وكان ذلك في كاس العالم 82
في اسبانيا لحساب مباراه تحديد المركز
الثالث والذي شهد تفوق النسور بثلاثه
اهداف على زملائي
[موسيقى]
بكاس العالم 2014
هو الاهم
الاسود الثلاثه منتخب انجلترا عبر الى هذا
الدور بافضل حصيله اهداف ثقه قسما مع
اسبانيا حين سجل 9 اهداف في ثلاث مباريات
ليواجهه اليوم الاحد منتخب السنغال في
دوري ال16 على ستاد البيت في الخور وتاهلت
السنغال الى الادوار الاقصائيه في كاس
العالم للمره الثانيه وكان ظهورها السابق
في دوري 16 في 2002 عندما كان المدرب
الحالي للسيسي يحمل اشاره قياده اسود
الثيرانغ ولم تخسر انجلترا امام اي منتخب
الافريقي في سبع مباريات في كاس العالم اذ
حقق اربعه انتصارات وتعادله ثلاث مرات مع
منتخبات من القاره السمراء
الانجليزي وصلوا الى هذه البطوله وهم
يحملون لقب اغلى منتخب في البطوله اسماء
من الرنان اجتمعت لاعاده الكاس الغائب عن
مهدي كره القدم منذ 56 عاما
الانتقادات طالت ساوت جاد قبل بدايه
البطوله واستمرت الى قبل مواجهه ثمن
النهائي وهو الرجل الذي قاد انجلترا الى
نصف نهائي البطوله الماضيه ونهاء النسخه
الماضيه من كاس اوروبا
اما المهاجم راشفورد فيبدو انه السعاده
ثقته بنفسه مع المنتخب بعد ان كان احدا
اللاعبين الثلاثه الذين اضعوا ركله
ترجيحيه امام ايطاليا في نهائي اليورو
اصبح احد المفاتيح المهمه في خط الهجوم
الانجليزيه
السنغال بطل افريقيا تمكن من تخطي دور
المجموعات للمره الثانيه خلال ثلاث
مشاركات له فقط مدربه اليوسي سي عرفه كيف
يستغل قدرات لاعبيه الذين ينشطون في اقوى
وابرز الفرق الاوروبيه المدرب السنغالي
يسعى لمعادله افضل انجازا للكره
السينغاليه في المونديال بالوصول الى ربع
النهائي وهو كان احد اعمده المنتخب كما ان
التجديد عقده قبل ايام من انطلاق المنافسه
ساعد السيسي في التركيز بشكل افضل على
تقديم اداء جيد خلال المباريات فهل تثبت
اسود التينجا بان المنتخبات الافريقيه
باتت رغما صعبا في البطوله اما ان واقعيه
الانجليز ستنهي المغامره السنغاليه
[موسيقى]
منذ المباراه الاولى قدم الرد الافضل على
كل ما مر به لقد قدم اداء مذهلا في
المباريات الثلاث التي خاضها حتى الان
وعلينا مواصله البناء لعبت الى جواره في
العديد من المباراه الدوليه وعشنا معا
العديد من اللحظات ولا يستحق ما مر به مع
ناديه
المهمه يوم الجمعه
الارشادات اللازمه وما علينا القيام به
نامل ان يكون متواجدا في الملعب يوم
المباراه وان يقود الفريق من ارض الملعب
هدفنا هو الصعود وانا متاكد ان اللاعبين
سيكونوا جاهزين ومستعدين ستكون مواجهه
صعبه لكن علينا ان نحافظ على الهدوء
كشفات تيتي مدرب البرازيل الاحد ان نيمار
سيشارك مع المنتخب في مباراه دوري 16 لكاس
العالم لكره القدم امام كوريا الجنوبيه
يوم غدا الاثنين واتلقى المدافع والتياغو
سيلفا سؤالا في مؤتمر صحفي بشان امكانيه
مشاركه نيمار في المباراه لكن التيتي
امسكت بالمايكروفون ورد بالايجاد اخذ
نيمار سباق مع زمن حتى يكون جاهزه
الاولى مباريات المجموعه السابعه
هذه كانت تفرز اخبار الرياضه وعوده الان
الى خالد مدخلي للاستكمال الرابع اليك
خالد
[موسيقى]
القمر يدور حول الكره الارضيه متى 10 مره
في الثانويه يلتقي في الثريا في كل شهر
مره خالد الزعت
[موسيقى]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون
القمر فاذا سمع جمالين الجمال الكوني
القمر وجمال النجوم الثريا قال العام
هالقمر جارنا ثريا فالمقارنه معناها
الاجتماع ولهذا سمي عقد النكاح بعقد قران
لانه جمع بين اثنين من الاصل لانهما
مفترقين فاذا وقع القمر بجانب الثريا يوم
الحادي عشر من الشهر الهجري قال العامه
قران عادي
فهو اماره علامه على بدايه البرد كحالي
ايامنا هذا انت القمر والشمس والارض
والكون وانت السماء وانت النجوم الرفيعه
وانت الذهب والماس غالي ومكنون يا دره
الخسران
من هو يبيعه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فالقمر يدور حول الكره الارضيه 12 مره بس
انا ويلتقي بثريا في كل شهر مره بمعنى انه
يلتقي به 12 مره هذا السنه سته منها لقيا
نهاريه غير مهمات وستا منها لقيا ليليه
وهذه المهمات فاهم الاقترانات سته اثنين
منها شتوي واثنين منها ربيعي واثنين منها
صيفي فاقتران شهر هذا قران عادي
وشهر الجاي جران تاسع بردي التاسع والشهر
اللي بعده جراند سابع مجيع وشابع اذا لم
ازر الا لي اكلي اكله فما رفع كفي الي
طعامي فما اكلت من التهاب بغنيمه ولا
جوعها
بغرامي
[موسيقى]
في ايران ودخولها شهرها الرابع النظام
يتراجع ويحل شرطه الاخلاق
المليوني برميل يوميا
مشاهده الصغيره والمتوسطه في السعوديه
يطلق اعماله باتفاقيات بقيمه ثلاثه
مليارات ريال
والمركز السعودي للارصاد يتوقعوا حاله
مطريه على معظم مناطق المملكه بدءا من
مساء اليوم
والسعوديون يتصدرون مشجع العالم في اطار
في اصدار بطاقه هيا لحضور مباريات مونديال
قطر
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]